[Musique]
la cité d'or se dresse au-dessus du
désert perdu à l'extrême ouest de l'Inde
la forteresse n'a pas bougé depuis le
Moyen Âge
et les mentalités aussi
les hommes depuis des millénaires
s'accrochent à une tradition barbare
il tue leur fille
[Musique]
sa Roja 11 ans et c'est une rescapée sa
mère s'est battue pour la garder et son
père heureusement a suivi
mais il y a eu un prix à payer pour ne
pas avoir respecté la tradition la
famille a dû quitter son village
chez mes pas vivre au village il n'y a
pas de fil à bas
en fait il n'y avait qu'une fille du
coup moi j'avais qu'une amie
le reste c'est que des garçons
[Musique]
pour cette société sa range comme
beaucoup de filles est un fardeau au
Rajasthan les filles ça ne travaille pas
ça ne rapporte pas d'argent elle ne
transmettent pas non plus le nom de la
famille et puis surtout un jour il faut
les marier ses filles et ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent
j'aime pas a donné quatre fois la vie
à sa Rodge donc à son petit frère
radjive mais aussi à deux autres filles
qu'elle n'a pas eu la force de sauver
quand tu as eu ta première fille tu as
dû la tuer toi-même
je l'ai tout fait avec du sable tu as
fait ça
c'est ma belle-mère qui m'a demandé ça
elle t'a dit de le faire mais tu as
essayé de refuser de lui dire non
non
tu as juste fait ce qu'elle te disait
je n'ai pas refusé parce que c'est la
tradition on n'a pas le choix il faut
écouter
personne ne peut refuser j'étais une
toute jeune fille qu'est-ce que je
pouvais faire tout le monde disait elle
a donné naissance à une fille on va la
tuer c'est notre tradition ils m'ont dit
de le faire et je l'ai fait
quand ma seconde fille est née ma
belle-sœur et ma belle-mère l'emprise
[Musique]
moi je me suis caché le visage je ne
voulais pas voir ça
elles ont mise dans une boîte
elle était nue elle n'avait pas d'habits
c'était tout de suite après sa naissance
c'est ce qu'on fait ici on les met dans
une boîte puis on les recouvre de terre
ensuite on les laisse comme ça toute la
nuit ils étouffement
le lendemain avant de lever du soleil
ils sont venus ils ont apporté la boîte
et sont partis l'enterrer quelque part
ils sont rentrés ils ont lavé leurs
mains leurs pieds et ils ont pris le
premier repas de la journée
elle te manque ta fille
continuer à vivre mais à quel prix il y
a les fantômes qui hante l'esprit de
Champa et puis la culpabilité qui ronge
celui de sa roche
celle d'être là
alors que ses sœurs n'ont plus aucune
chance
[Musique]
et puis il y a la vie qui sans cesse
rappelle ce souvenir chaque retour au
village qui est douloureux
à mesure que des fils le bitume on
rejoint le cœur de la tragédie le lieu
où cette tradition des infanticides
prend racines
ce village c'est l'un de ceux qui
comptent aujourd'hui le plus grand
déséquilibre entre hommes et femmes de
tout le continent indien
donc habite là on est au bout du monde
et après l'école il n'y a que des
garçons pour jouer dans ses rues
poussiéreuses
[Musique]
sa mère l'emmène chez la femme qui lui a
sauvé la vie
c'était il y a 11 ans
soyez les bienvenus
[Musique]
allez on y va
est une figure connue dans tout le
Rajasthan c'est la première femme il y a
30 ans avoir défié l'ordre établi à
cette opposée à l'infanticide
cette femme d'un milieu aisé est devenue
le modèle de milliers de villageoises
comme Champa
sauver les filles elle insiste les
filles doivent vivre mais les femmes du
village n'écoutent pas ses paroles elle
m'a expliqué que garder ma fille était
juste ce sont des choses que je ne
comprenais pas avant mais dont je suis
consciente aujourd'hui c'est parce que
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps avec elle
quand ma première fille est née ma
famille n'était pas contente du tout
ma belle-mère en particulier
il se réjouissait tous à l'idée d'avoir
un garçon
personne bien sûr ne m'a dit en face
qu'il ne voulait pas garder ma fille
mais c'est parce que mon mari était à
mes côtés qu'elle est vivante
aujourd'hui
il m'a soutenu de toute son autorité et
leur a dit personne ne frappe problème à
ma femme
les enfants qui naîtront ici dans cette
maison quel que soit leur sexe ils
veulent
à partir de ce moment des femmes du
village sont venues me chercher
régulièrement elle me disait ma
belle-famille ne veut pas garder ma
fille il faut que tu leur parles allez
viens
avec gadjendra une toute petite
révolution est en marche dans ces
villages
[Musique]
sa Rodge en tout cas
lui sera reconnaissant à jamais mais
pour sa vie sauvée combien d'autres
encore continueront à être sacrifié
[Musique]
c'est le chant des morts qui plane
aujourd'hui au-dessus du village
[Musique]
chaque mois on leur rend hommage chaque
mois aussi c'est ce jour que choisissent
les hommes pour se réunir
[Musique]
les pancciates ce sont des tribunaux
populaires des organisations
officiellement interdites mais qui
régissent encore la vie de centaines de
millions d'Indiens dans les campagnes
ici on s'accroche au pouvoir tout autant
qu'autre traditions
[Musique]
mon nom est malabouchonne je suis un
guerrier rage scout
j'ai 6 enfants tous des garçons
ils sont mariés et chacun d'entre eux a
eu deux fils
que des garçons mais c'est juste de la
chance
les guerriers du Rajasthan on est très
attachés à la domination des hommes si
une fille fait des études elle
n'écoutera plus son père et sa mère elle
voudra alors voir du monde sortir de la
maison comment on peut laisser sortir
une fille
si quelqu'un du village la voit traînée
dehors les gens viendront voir on a vu
ta fille traîner avec des garçons on
sera alors montré du doigt et plus grave
cette fille-là on ne pourra plus jamais
la marier
on a peur de ça si elles deviennent
légales des hommes elle ne voudront plus
travailler à la maison c'est pour ça que
personne ne veut que les filles soient
éduqués elle pourrait rompre avec notre
culture j'ai déjà vu ça bien des fois et
j'en ai tiré mes conclusions
si on ne garde pas nos filles c'est
parce qu'elle coûte beaucoup d'argent
tout au moment du mariage
il faut l'équivalent de 15000 euros au
moins pour une fille alors imaginez si
on en avait trois
les belles familles réclament 8000 euros
au moins pour les fiançailles puis 15000
euros le jour du mariage pour accepter
notre fille dans leur famille
[Musique]
les gens parlent toujours des filles
qu'on tue mais ils ne connaissent pas
tous nos problèmes
sur ces terres les hommes tiennent les
mêmes discours depuis des siècles les
traditions et les coutumes sont
profondément ancrées
[Musique]
personne ici ne veut parler directement
des infanticides mais ces hommes ont été
élevés ainsi par leur père et ses
valeurs il les transmettront à leur fils
pas facile pour gadjendra de faire face
à ce conservatisme en 30 années elle a
bien sauvé quelques fillettes mais elle
sait que ce drame se poursuit dans
beaucoup de maisons à l'abri des regards
voyez cette maison là juste en face et
bien dans cette maison ils ont tué au
moins 6 ou 7 petites filles
officiellement aucune de leurs belles
filles n'a donné naissance à une fille
il n'y a que des garçons qui naissent
chez eux
venez on s'en va
regardez cette autre maison là
une fille aînée mais la mère ne voulait
pas s'en occuper
je lui ai dit tu vas aller en prison si
tu te débarrasses de ta fille alors elle
s'est calme et un certain temps
quand elle est sortie de l'hôpital et
rentrer au village je suis retourné la
voir puis je suis rentré me coucher le
lendemain matin j'ai appris que sa
famille avait tué le bébé et alors mon
cœur s'est rempli l'amertume
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le cœur de Champa lui est rempli de
crainte
avec sa fille ce soir elle ne rentreront
pas à la maison
nous a parlé sans l'autorisation de son
mari et il est foudrages elle va passer
la nuit chez une amie en espérant que
demain la colère sera retombée
j'ai peur de mon mari ce n'est pas dans
notre culture dans notre tradition de
parler comme ça mon mari va hurler je ne
sais pas ce qu'il va me faire s'il me
retrouve ce soir il va boire et puis il
va se mettre à ma recherche après il va
peut-être même me battre je ne sais pas
c'est notre vie on ne pourra jamais
quitter nos maris si on les quitté ce
sera un crime on nous ferait passer pour
des folles donc toute notre vie on
n'aura pas d'autres choix que de suivre
nos maris peu importe ce qu'ils font peu
importe qu'ils aient raison ou tort on
est condamné à les suivre
les hommes ne veulent pas et que les
choses changent ils veulent conserver
leur position leur autorité ils veulent
continuer à décider de chaque chose mais
un jour peut-être il se mettront à
prendre en considération nos idées ce
jour-là ça voudra dire qu'on est libre
alors on s'arrêtera de s'occuper de leur
maison on ne fera plus rien et enfin ils
auront perdu leur autorité et tout leur
droit
sinon mon mari me tuerait